So today we're going to be talking about
old versus young the reality of dating
for men and for women oh my gosh I have
so much to say about this because of
Twitter yes because of Twitter you know
I always talk to the most intelligent
and bright people on Twitter I have been
accused of hating women because
geriatric pregnancy starts at 35. and
this is the misconception that the red
pill says is it hating women to let them
know at 35 you're basically biologically
useless to men
um and maybe we should try to have kids
earlier rather than later and do the
best that we can to achieve that is it
wouldn't
that's 18 to hear 16
16. honestly guys I'm not really worried
about the the women the older women
because I mean I I think it's tough to
deprogram most of this stuff what I'm
thinking about is the next generation of
women that look at the older women that
give them bad advice